en el vídeo anterior vimos dos métodos
diferentes para formar un óxido a partir
de un al que no el primer método fue
agregar un proxy ácido
el segundo método fue primero formar una
halo y drina usando bromo en agua
y después usar hidróxido de sodio
para comenzar una síntesis de williamson
intra molecular para formar nuestro
epoxy 2 en este vídeo veremos la estéreo
química de la formación de epoxy 2 con
cualquiera de estas dos reacciones
sí
dos hidrógenos se encuentran en el mismo
lado del doble enlace o los grupos
r están en el mismo lado del doble
enlace en el producto los grupos
r van a seguir estando en la misma
posición donde el doble enlace se
encontraba si observamos un al que no
trans
y sabemos que es trans porque mis
hidrógenos están en lados opuestos o los
grupos r
están en lados opuestos del doble enlace
y en el producto
los grupos r
van a seguir estando en lados opuestos
con respecto al lugar en donde se
encontraba el doble enlace
así que vamos a ver la reacción junto
con su estéreo química entonces si
comenzó con un al que no y voy a poner
un grupo metilo aquí
y voy a colocar un grupo estilo aquí y
voy a tener mis hidrógenos así
si hago reaccionar este al que no
con cualquiera de los dos con cualquiera
de los dos reactivos y solo voy a
escribir un símbolo de ídem aquí
entonces cualquiera de los dos reactivos
van a darme el mismo producto si pienso
en la formación
de un óxido
entonces sé que voy a formar un epoxy do
y sé que necesito tener esos grupos
cerré en lados opuestos del lugar en
donde estaba el doble enlace
entonces un producto posible sería tener
el grupo estilo saliendo del plano hacia
mí y por lo tanto el grupo metilo
estaría saliendo del plano lejos de mí
así
si este es mi producto en este carbono
de la izquierda
debo tener microgen o saliendo del plano
lejos de mí y en este carbono de la
derecha debo tener mi hidrógeno saliendo
del plano hacia mí así por lo que ese es
un posible producto y podría también
dibujar otro producto en el que mis
grupos r estén en lados opuestos del
lugar donde se encontraba el doble
enlace entonces podría tener podría
tener el grupo estilo
saliendo del plano lejos de mí
a la izquierda y por lo tanto
el grupo metilo saliendo del plano hacia
mí en el carbono de la derecha así
y entonces esto tendría un hidrógeno
saliendo del plano hacia mí y luego este
carbono tendría un hidrógeno saliendo
del plano lejos de mí así entonces tengo
dos posibles productos y estas dos
moléculas son en anti américas la una de
la otra así que estaríamos creando una
mezcla la semi k 50% de un enantiómero y
50% del otro ya que esta reacción crea
dos centros virales nuevos entonces se
observó esta molécula estos
carbono son centros finales por lo que
hay estéreo química en ambos carbonos
así que cuando dibuja los enantiómero si
comenzamos con esta molécula de la
izquierda tengo mi grupo e hilo saliendo
del plano hacia mí y todo lo que hay que
hacer es revertir la configuración
absoluta para lograr que el grupo
pilot
salga del plano lejos de mí para obtener
el enantiómero de la derecha
si vemos el si vemos el centro que ir al
de este lado tengo mi grupo metilo
saliendo del plano lejos de mí y todo lo
que tengo que hacer es revertir la
configuración absoluta y así tener el
grupo metilo saliendo del plano hacia mí
así que estos dos son enantiómero el uno
del otro y veamos ahora el detalle de la
formación de estos dos enantiómero y
después los nombraremos utilizando
estéreo química entonces si empezamos
con este al que no ve la izquierda si
empezamos con ese al que no
y pensamos en estos dos carbonos
carbonos tienen hibridación sp2 es decir
que la molécula es plana en estos dos
carbonos
entonces puedo pensar en este al que no
como una molécula plana en esos dos
carbonos así que voy a dibujar la
molécula aquí pondré el grupo
y lo aquí en la izquierda y el hidrógeno
aquí y luego voy a tener un hidrógeno
aquí
un grupo estilo así entonces es la misma
molécula es la misma molécula que esta
otra de la izquierda pero la gire un
poco y ahora sé que esos dos carbonos en
ambos lados del doble enlace tienen
hibridación sp2 es decir que
porción
de la molécula es plana entonces puedo
pensar en esa porción de la molécula
como plana y por lo tanto puedo pensar
en que el oxígeno se añadirá en
cualquiera de los dos lados del plano
bien entonces el oxígeno se puede añadir
en la parte de arriba del plano o en la
parte de abajo del plano así que vamos a
dibujar las resultantes de añadir el
oxígeno de un lado o del otro entonces
del lado izquierdo
voy a pensar en lo que le ocurre a la
molécula cuando el oxígeno se une a la
parte superior del plano entonces si el
oxígeno se añade a la parte superior del
plano voy a continuar
voy a conservar el grupo
metilo y el grupo
tilo en lados opuestos del lugar donde
se encontraba el doble enlace y por lo
tanto los dos hidrógenos también van a
estar en lados opuestos del lugar donde
se encontraba el doble enlace y voy a
mostrar el oxígeno unido a la parte
superior del plano entonces
el óxido quedaría así
entonces esa es una posible manera de
formar un epoxi do así que ahora
pensemos cómo se vería el óxido si el
oxígeno se uniera a la parte inferior
del plano
entonces si el oxígeno se uniera a la
parte inferior del plano una vez más
tenemos que pensar en conservar el grupo
metilo
grupo estilo en lados opuestos del lugar
donde se encontraba el doble enlace y
los hidrógenos
también van a estar en lados opuestos
del lugar donde se encontraba el doble
enlace así y luego vamos a mostrar el
oxígeno unido a la parte inferior del
plano para la formación del epoxi 2
entonces nuestro epoxi 2 se vería así
estos son mis dos posibles productos y
estos son en ante o meros el uno del
otro pero es difícil apreciarlo en los
dibujos que acabamos de hacer
así que veamos si le podemos dar otra
perspectiva a nuestros epoxy 2 voy a
pretender que
están aquí y que observo a la molécula
belle époque sido desde aquí entonces se
observó este epoc sido puedo volver a
dibujar luz y óxido aquí voy a colocar
esa porción de la molécula así ahora
si la observo de esta manera entonces
voy a ver primero el carbono del lado
izquierdo que sería este carbono de aquí
y puedo ver que hay un grupo estilo
saliendo del plano hacia mí así que voy
a dibujar
un grupo estilo
saliendo del plano hacia mí y puedo ver
que hay un hidrógeno saliendo del plano
lejos de mí espero que sea mi mente qué
es
e hidrógeno está saliendo del plano
lejos de mí y que pueda hacer así su
representación
así que pondré unas líneas aquí que
muestran el hidrógeno lejos de mí y
ahora vamos a ver el carbono del lado
derecho este carbono del otro lado aquí
puedo ver que el hidrógeno está saliendo
del plano hacia mí así que voy a dibujar
al hidrógeno saliendo del plano hacia mí
así y por lo tanto este grupo metilo de
aquí que está saliendo del plano lejos
de mí voy a dibujar
y lo saliendo lejos de mí así
entonces ese es uno de los delanteros y
ahora vamos a volver a dibujar la
molécula de la derecha de nuevo si
observo se observa al stoke sido así
que veo pues vería al óxido como si
estuviera de cabeza entonces el oxígeno
estaría aquí abajo
y puedo ver que si observo al carbono de
la izquierda desde mi nueva perspectiva
que sería este carbono de aquí puedo ver
que hay un grupo de tilo saliendo del
plano hacia mí aquí está mi grupo estilo
saliendo del plano hacia mí
el hidrógeno estaría saliendo lejos de
mí representaré a ese hidrógeno
saliendo lejos
así y luego si observamos ese carbono
del lado derecho puedo ver que este
hidrógeno está saliendo del plano hacia
mí así que puedo dibujar
hidrógeno saliendo del plano hacia mí y
el grupo metilo de aquí estaría saliendo
del plano lejos de mí entonces puedo
poner al grupo metilo con unas líneas
este es uno de mis productos
no es tan evidente que estos son
enantiómero así que aquí es donde tener
un prototipo modelo nos es útil entonces
si observas esta molécula de la derecha
y luego tomas este este oxígeno y rotas
este oxígeno hacia arriba es más fácil
de ver con el prototipo modelo verás
verás que esta molécula es exactamente
la misma molécula que la que vamos a
dibujar
aquí
entonces si la rotamos de manera que el
oxígeno apunte hacia arriba eso va a
hacer que esté
hidrógeno de aquí atrás que de adelante
así que cuando dibujas esta molécula
rota da ese hidrógeno se va a pasar
hacia el frente lo que empuja al grupo
de tilo hacia atrás entonces el grupo
estilo se va a mover a la parte de atrás
ocurre lo mismo con el grupo metilo este
grupo metilo estaba en la parte de atrás
cuando los rotos así el grupo metilo
terminará saliendo
del plano hacia ti
y eso implica que el hidrógeno va a
salir del plano lejos de ti
entonces ahora espero que podamos ver
que estos dos son enantiómero el uno del
otro
ahora pensemos en cómo nombrar estos
productos
entonces si fuera a nombrar estas dos
moléculas tengo que pensar en cómo
hacerlo entonces tengo que encontrar la
cadena más larga de carbono y le quiero
dar a mi sustituye ente epoxi el número
más bajo posible así que voy a enumerar
mi cadena de carbono haré que este sea
mi carbono número uno
este carbono el número 2
5 así entonces voy a nombrarlo pentano
así que sería
en
no
así y puedo ver que mi grupo epoxi se
encuentra entre los carbonos 2 y 3
entonces sería
así entonces este enantiómero sería 23
epoxy ventana
este lo sería también así que puedo
escribir
epoxy
ya no
azul pero ahora tengo que pensar en la
estéreo química en los carbonos 2 y 3 y
eso complica un poco las cosas entonces
voy a observar el enantiómero de la
izquierda y voy a volver a dibujar el
enantiómero de la izquierda voy a volver
a dibujar este
aquí y veamos si podemos empezar a
asignarle algo de estéreo química
entonces tengo mi hidrógeno saliendo
hacia mí y tengo mi grupo metilo
saliendo lejos de mí
el grupo estilo sale hacia mí
hidrógeno
sale lejos de mí empecemos empezamos con
este carbono si quiero conocer la
configuración absoluta de ese carbono
tengo que pensar en los átomos que están
directamente unidos a ese carbono
entonces vamos a dibujar ese carbono
aquí este es uno de los átomos
directamente unidos a ese carbono en
color azul
entonces el carbono en azul está
directamente unido a este carbono este
oxígeno
de hidrógeno y este carbono de aquí
abajo esos serían los cuatro átomos
entonces si estoy determinando prioridad
pienso en el número atómico y sé que el
oxígeno tiene el número atómico más alto
de los cuatro átomos así que el oxígeno
tendría el número uno el hidrógeno tiene
la prioridad más baja por lo que le
damos el número cuatro
ahora tengo que pensar en estos dos
carbonos porque si hay un empate tengo
que pensar que están unidos
esos dos carbonos bien el carbono de la
derecha este carbono de aquí este
carbono de aquí está unido a un oxígeno
voy a escribir esto aquí el carbono de
la derecha está directamente unido a un
oxígeno está directamente unido está
directamente unido a un carbono y está
directamente unido a un hidrógeno
así que son oxígeno carbono
hidrógeno
ahora vamos a ver al carbono de la
izquierda este carbono de aquí a que
está unido este carbono está unido a
este otro carbono y a dos hidrógenos
h
h entonces el oxígeno le gana al carbono
en términos de número atómico y este
carbono de la derecha tendrá la
prioridad más alta por lo que este
carbono tendrá el número
2 y entonces este otro carbono tendrá el
número
en configuración absoluta mi prioridad
más baja se está alejando de mí y voy
girando en este sentido voy en sentido
de las manecillas del reloj por lo que
la configuración absoluta de este
carbono es r
y ahora vamos a como este dibujo está
lleno vamos a dibujarlo nuevamente y
veremos la configuración absoluta del
otro carbono veamos seguimos teniendo al
grupo estilo saliendo hacia mí y
seguimos teniendo al hidrógeno saliendo
lejos de mí
teniendo
pero genoa saliendo hacia mí y seguimos
teniendo a este grupo metilo
saliendo lejos de mí
así entonces sí estoy descifrando la
configuración absoluta de este carbono
tendremos que hacerlo de la misma manera
observen a los átomos directamente
unidos a este carbono serían oxígeno
carbono carbono e hidrógeno ahora
prioridad es el oxígeno tiene la
prioridad más alta
el hidrógeno la prioridad más baja y
luego este carbono de aquí está
directamente unido a un oxígeno así que
tendrá la
segunda prioridad más alta y eso
convierte a este grupo metilo de aquí en
la
prioridad entonces el 1 2 3 va girando
en este sentido que es en contra de las
manecillas del reloj lo que hace pensar
que podría ser ese
recuerden el truco que les conté en un
vídeo anterior parece ese pero el
hidrógeno sale hacia mí entonces lo que
hay que hacer es cambiar esto y así nos
hacemos cargo del hecho de que el grupo
con menor prioridad no esté apuntando
lejos de mí
entonces parece ese pero como el
hidrógeno apunta hacia mí puedo decir
con confianza que su configuración
absoluta es r
así que ahora podemos completar el
nombre en el carbono 2 y en el carbono 3
tenemos una configuración absoluta r así
que el nombre de este enlace homero
sería 2 r
23 epoxy pentano y para este enantiómero
de la derecha yo sé que es el
enantiómero así que sólo tengo que
cambiar la configuración absoluta
entonces este va a ser
2 s
occidental
no tenemos tiempo en este vídeo para
asignar configuración absoluta al
enantiómero de la derecha pero puedes
intentar hacerlo como práctica y
deberías obtener que su configuración
absoluta es 12 ce 3s este es un problema
porque si estás formando una mezcla race
mica de tu epoxi do eso no es lo que
usualmente quieres en química orgánica
hay maneras de utilizar catalizadores
quirales que nos permiten seleccionar
uno de estos en arte o meros no
cubriremos ese tema en estos vídeos ya
que estos tratan solo introducción a
química orgánica pero sepan que es
posible seleccionar que enantiómero
producir